es ist ein trauriger anblick auf dem
köppel bei montabaur
vor drei jahren war das hier noch ein
dichter fichtenwald heute ist es
brachland
es sei schockierend wie schnell dieser
wandel vonstatten gegangen sei sagt
förster stefan koch auch wenn einige
bäume sich immer noch halten und hin und
wieder etwas grün zu sehen ist
wir haben andere teile wie wir es jetzt
weiter hinten sehen wo wir auf sehr
großer fläche hektar weise sozusagen
kahlen verbrannten karge boden haben wo
im moment überhaupt nichts wächst drei
jahre mit heißen sommern und zu wenig
wasser obwohl der westerwald sonst für
ihr raues klima und hohe
niederschlagsmengen bekannt ist
schätzungsweise 90 prozent aller fichten
hier sind bereits tot fällen die einzige
option die bleibt der großteil dieses
schadholz es gehe nach china sagt martin
greive von der kommunalen
holzvermarktung das führe zu hohen
transportkosten und somit zu hohen
verlusten für die waldbesitzer weil wir
diese diese situation fast in ganz
mitteleuropa haben ist natürlich der
regionale holzrad absolut überfüllt also
wir haben hier das vier bis fünffache
holz aufgebot was die lokalen sägewerk
und holzindustrie verarbeiten können und
deswegen haben wir diese an über angebot
was dann die preise im keller sind lässt
aber auch die holzqualität ist massiv
gesunken
düstere aussichten für den westerwald
der nicht nur geldquellen versiegen
zwischenzeitlich wurde 2020 auch das
wasser knapp im hirschbach reicht einem
das normalerweise bis zu den knien viele
grund und damit trinkwasserquellen der
verbandsgemeinde hachenburg befinden
sich im wald das problem viele tote
bäume führen zu weniger wasser
der moment wo ein baum tod ist sind auch
die wurzeln tod das heißt die das wasser
erhalten im boden funktioniert nicht
mehr das was er singt in tiefere
bodenschichten ab und es kommt zu einer
zunehmenden austrocknung an der
oberfläche die trinkwasser produktion
einiger quellen im wald sei im sommer
2020 um 75 prozent zurückgegangen
generell sei die versorgung nicht
gefährdet dennoch könnte sie künftig
teuer werden
wir könnten darüber nachdenken neue
brunnen zu bohren die sind 150 meter
tief kosten der viertel- bis zu einer
halben million euro und haben über das
hohe risiko dass vielleicht doch kein
wasser da ist oder nur kurzzeitig wasser
da es auch im harz leidet der wald forst
wird meyer stork ist immer wieder
fassungslos
alle seine alten fichten sterben
der borkenkäfer hat sie befallen diese
fläche die jetzt vor uns liegt das war
wie gesagt letztes jahr noch
geschlossener dunkler wald die bäume
sind über 170 jahre alt das ist das ist
unglaublich was hier passiert ist
gut 100 hektar nadelwald bewirtschaftet
der 58 jährige mit seiner familie im
ostharz bei oldenburg nach trockenheit
und borkenkäferbefall musste er fast
alles fällen um wieder aufzuforsten
fehlt ihnen das geld dadurch dass wir
eben dieses diesen dieses einkommen
durchgehend durch das verkauf des
gesunden fichtenholz ist nicht nur haben
das hat vorher alles gut geklappt da
konnten wir uns pflanzen kaufen
das fällt natürlich jetzt weg ja es ist
schon das geschäft halbiert sich
sozusagen der nadelwald im ganzen
ostharz stirbt rasak brauner
fleckenteppich statt sattem grün
mindestens 30.000 hektar sind geschädigt
so der waldbesitzerverband das
entspricht der fläche bremens
hauptursache der borkenkäfer um ihn
abzuwehren muss die fichte harz bilden
aufgrund der trockenheit können die
bäume das nicht deshalb werden frisch
befallene bäume gefällt und zwar schnell
wie hier bei schierke am rand des
nationalparks harz so soll der käfer
sich nicht weiter ausbreiten können
da ist jetzt gerade dabei seine
vermehrung sein spaß bild anzulegen und
sich munter zu vermehren und unsere in
das grundstück besteht bin ihnen während
dieses prozesses zu erwischen und samt
seiner brut auszufahren
zurück bleiben kahle flächen im
nationalpark und irritierte wanderer
eine landschaft hier etwas ganz anderes
als wanderer auch kein schatten mehr
waldsterben ist schon traurig hier aber
ansonsten ist es schön
ja definitiv ist katastrophe neulich war
ich hier da war ich in einer da waren so
viele borkenkäfer auf dem weg da
konntest du nicht ordnung
das war wie eine wolke lauern als kleine
geschlüpfte randvoll 2020 hat der
borkenkäfer im nationalpark harz 20 mal
mehr wald befallen als noch im jahr 2018
waldsterben ist hier ansicht teil des
gewünschten wandels vom nadelwald hin
zum ursprünglichen laubwald die
geschwindigkeit mit der das geschieht
überrascht jedoch selbst die
naturschützer dass bäume absterben ist
für nationalpark nicht ungewöhnlich weil
wir ja das motto haben natur natur sein
lassen
das sage ich mal das wasser tief rein
geht es eigentlich darum stein die
geschwindigkeit der letzten beiden jahre
wo das passiert ist jetzt ist es
tatsächlich so dass ich von woche zu
woche veränderte wald und das sind schon
ja das geht nicht so spurlos an einem
vorbei natur natur sein lassen bedeutet
auch tote bäume bleiben im nationalpark
stehen
dieser anblick habe zwar bisher im
urlaubsort schierke noch keine touristen
abgeschreckt und doch sieht
bürgermeisterin christiane hopstock im
totholz am nordrand eine gefahr
ein riesen gefahr für uns besteht ja
also ich denke es wäre schon besser wenn
die verantwortlichen des nationalparks
bestreiten eine erhöhte waldbrandgefahr
und wollen stämme als biomasse für den
neuen wald stehen lassen
die immensen schäden an seinen pflichten
muss privatwaldbesitzer cornelius meyer
stork selbst stemmen
für die zukunft setzt er auf einen
robusten mischwald aus buche douglasien
weißtanne und kastanie allerdings ohne
garantien
das ist noch nie so schwer gewesen weit
zu begründen wie vielleicht vor 300
jahren da war es einfacher das ist heute
deutlich schwerer weil man eben diese
ungewissheit hat was letztlich dann auch
dauerhaft wachsen kann
ja es kann ja noch wärmer werden ob aus
dieser bereits neu bepflanzten fläche
mal ein gesunder harz wald entsteht wird
sich erst in jahrzehnten zeigen
noch nie ging es dem deutschen wald so
schlecht die zahl abgestorbener bäume
hat sich in einem jahr verdoppelt fast
80 prozent des bestandes sind geschädigt
große flächen müssen wieder bepflanzt
werden
doch wie im pfälzer wald wird seit über
30 jahren die beständigkeit ein
heimischer baumarten erforscht bei der
wiederaufforstung empfehlen die experten
hier zurückhaltung bei unbekannten
ausländischen sorten doch eine
erfolgsgarantie für die einheimischen
können sie auch nicht geben
wunderbare gibt es nicht alle unsere
baumarten haben ihre vor und nachteile
die größten nachteile hat die fichte
wenn man die zukunft gibt aber auch
andere baumarten haben nachteil
deswegen ist unsere haupt empfehlung
immer in lösung zu bieten
die klimamodelle für die zukunft
verheißen nichts gutes
zwei bis vier grad höhere temperaturen
bis ende des jahrhunderts dazu weiter
geringe niederschläge
jetzt gilt es vor allem das ökosystem
wald zu sichern
die vitalität und stabilität der wilde
wälder muss im vordergrund stehen es
geht mehr und mehr um den walderhalt um
die fähigkeit unserer wälder solche
extremen bedingungen die durch den
klimawandel kommen sowie darstellen das
muss absolut im vordergrund stehen
der zustand des waldes und die folgen
für viele menschen im westerwald ist
dass der klimawandel direkt vor der
haustür
die sorge um die natur treibt auch in
altenkirchen die friday is for future
bewegung auf die straße die ganzen haben
also die fichten zurzeit die meldung
dass die buch und als nächstes dran sind
und ja die vegetation verändert sich es
zeigt was ja was ist jetzt schon für
schlimme auswirkungen hat und man kann
sich dann vorstellen was es woanders auf
der welt noch für viel gravierendere
auswirkungen hat es gibt keine pilze
weil es zu trocken ist
es ist die natur die ist so am leiden
dass man es kaum aushalten kann
auf diesem eingezäunten gelände bei
montabaur will förster stefan koch
künftig eichen pflanzen die kämen besser
mit trockenheit zu recht als fichten
angesichts der risiken verdorrten fläche
wirkt das wie der berühmte tropfen auf
den heißen stein
das komplette areal neu aufzuforsten
wäre finanziell nicht zu stemmen
und es wäre auch nicht sinnvoll so koch
er ist überzeugt die natur hilft sich
selbst braucht aber zeit
diese maßnahme ist eben dann eine im
kleinen rahmen die aber auch zum
beispiel der eiche in 100 jahren
ermöglichen soll sich hier in dem
bereich zu etablieren
trotz solcher bilder bleibe er
optimistisch sagt steffen koch
vielleicht gibt es künftig wieder mehr
regen vielleicht erholt sich der wald
von alleine
dass sei seine ganz persönliche hoffnung
so der förster keine prognose